i'd give all the sins back if this was
subtitled star wars visions if the
vision you have pleases the majority of
the fan base and if it does not we will
make rise of the skywalker star wars
property opening on a shot of space
cliche yomi tori what's with this black
and white pencil drawn stuff don't you
know it's 20 21 and all art has to be
pristine digital renders with
complicated and off-putting cg
characters did lucas teach you nothing
with the special editions also do you
know how fast the wind has to be blowing
to make this big of a chomagay fly
around like this for this long me either
but it seems unlikely it wouldn't at
least be the tops of these trees behind
him should be at least swaying miles per
hour man it's incredible to see star
wars kurosawa influence back in the
hands of the culture it came from so i
could remove a sin for the beauty of
seeing it in its intended form or i
could send lucas for cribbing it in the
first place you make the call pause the
video right now to vote in the comments
and then the current leading vote will
be revealed when you press play
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
democracy it must be lonesome traveling
the countryside all by yourself must be
hard to keep all your body parts intact
when you're a shopkeeper who makes too
many personal comments to passers-by
with swords you know what i take back
the hair comment it's apparent now that
he's just styled it in the form of wind
blown and has installed a fan in the
back of his skull to keep it in motion
my mistake silly me forget all of these
pedestrians getting out of the way i'm
calling [ __ ] that a vehicle this
large and wide could get down this
narrow street without taking out at
least one or two dwellings how did it
even make the initial turn this is the
deadman tell no tales bank robbery all
over again and i'm not having it trying
to play any sort of table game in a
bumpy transport vehicle give us your
goods it's time for you to pay your
taxes
that was a direct order jeez over the
top henchman guy give the sentence a
second to sink in before going full
sergeant hartman on these poor villagers
i am the current chief now for the love
of [ __ ] dune i'm tired of child rulers
who show wisdom and poise beyond their
years if this kid really was the chief
of this place where's the local chuck e
cheese he had installed for skee-ball
purposes huh
the guards will handle them run for
cover i feel like if the village already
has a hand signal in place everyone
should already know that means run for
cover the kid is having to waste
precious time by expositioning all this
after the fact if the villagers had
these t-1000s ready to go why did they
wait to unleash them until the enemy
vehicle docked and had everyone captured
this swordship is hilarious why would
you limit a flying vehicle by making its
primary weapons close combat blades
especially ones that have to be ground
level to use you had the high ground
wearing heels into combat
lightsabers she's a seth here's a thing
i just said out loud for no one's
benefit but the audiences keep firing
don't give her a chance just drive
immediately followed by a pause in
firing as she uses her sabrella ella
ella a a a to poppins herself down to
your level while being fully susceptible
to gunfire run don't engage in close
combat talking during battle instead of
fighting seriously why are all these
tactics not discussed prior to battle
kind of hard to win if you're having to
shout out instructions while being
attacked you don't look like one of the
villagers that's villagerist wait is
that the original star wars poster
[Laughter]
is the local theater playing a new hope
i mean some things are easter eggs and
others are just easter wtf's droids
wearing hats guess i won't be needing
this anymore
[Music]
so you're a jedi while the man with no
name trilogy ends up not being a jedi
he's still a badass and so convenient
badass shows up in no-name town when
needed is badass but convenient your
lightsaber blade is red no not red i
mean i'm sure that actually means
something to someone but i didn't
actually climax after hearing it so i
feel like that deserves a sin
hiding this glorious hairstyle for this
long how did you even manage to keep it
contained the sheer boldness of that
boundless bouffant could conquer the
galaxy deciding now is finally time to
man the turret and take out the watch
towers sure this is a baller move but is
it the best strategy she's now limited
her maneuverability by being stuck on a
small log in rapidly flowing water she
could have kept the battle on land and
maybe even found higher ground i do hear
that's important also timber sports
i was already getting huge animatrix
vibes off this project but now you're
cutting pieces of clothing off during
battle so if this short doesn't go full
final flight of the osiris i will be
disappointed spoiler alert i'm always
disappointed turning your back when
facing someone with a lightsaber
how does this even work is the saber
still on inside the sheath is it off and
somehow secured at the top of the sheath
making the whole sheath useless in jedi
middle school health when they taught
about sheathing your saber i don't think
this is what they meant
[Music]
wait why did grandmaster here have to
shoot this guy did discount r2 shoot
enough missiles to take out all the
baddies including the one on the distant
cliff except this one
stabbing someone in the back here
for your troubles oh a benton discarded
umbrella skeleton that is non-functional
without a lightsaber gee thanks mister
key character completes quest to kill
contemporaries and collect corpse's
kyber crystals cool take care of this
it wards off evil you know what else
helps fight evil a functional lightsaber
space
the final frontier i'm popping y'all
your lightsaber blade is
right what is your favorite color
look at that droid these aren't the
droids you're looking for
good chocolate